Genome sequencing allows us to actually
identify and pinpoint mutations
which can then help us to understand what brought about the cancer in the first place.
We've sequenced several Tasmanian Devil
Tumour Disease genomes now
and we identified a mutation involved in
one gene in the Tasmanian devil cancer
known as platelet-derived growth factor A or PDGFA for short.
A number of human cancers have mutations in the PDGFA gene
or in the PDGFA receptor.
There are a number of drugs that have been developed
which specifically inhibit the PDGFA
receptor
and these have been found to be quite effective in some kinds of human cancers.
So this leads to some interesting possibilities
of using this drug in the Tasmanian devil cancer
so could perhaps be an effective treatment in this cancer too.